your life did profoundly change but do
you look back and say you know I
wouldn't be where I am today but weren't
for that do you have a different a
different view of those first 38 years
and all those crazy jobs although I was
a failure I never gave up I kept trying
I kept writing I tried journalism I
didn't do well and I tried writing
novels I didn't do well and I tried
writing screenplays didn't do well and I
kept trying trying and trying and and I
had all of these experiences with bosses
and power and it all went into the soup
that became the 48 Laws of Power if the
same man came to me when I was 25 to
write the book I wouldn't have been able
to so everything had a purpose behind it